journalistes et bien sont interroger
collectivement par les français puisque
environ 60 % d'entre eux posent la question
de leur indépendance par rapport au poids
politique et ils sont presque aussi nombreux à
la pause et par rapport au pouvoir économique à
l'argent l'atelier des médias ziad maalouf
j'ai toujours trouvé étrange ces sondages
d'opinion qui évalue la confiance que prête les
individus aux organes de presse aux journalistes
il y a tellement de types de médias de qualité
de publications différentes que cela me paraît
absurde voire malhonnête de classe et tout le
monde ensemble que pensez-vous des restaurateurs
que pensez-vous des écrivains que pensez-vous
des chanteurs que pensez-vous des plombiers
c'est sûr que si l'on pose ce type de questions
à un individu il aura toujours quelque chose à
dire à penser il est également certain que sa
réponse aura une importance toute relative il
ira au restaurant il appellera un plombier il
écoutera des chanteurs il ira des romans tout
cela selon ses choix 16 ans fuit ses goûts par
quel miracle mettre tous les médias dans le même
sac pour les juger aurait une valeur informative
plus importantes les plus grands détracteurs des
médias sont d'ailleurs les premiers à les citer
les partager les caumontais se tourner vers eux
quand ils ont besoin de s'informer ils savent
où se doute que le parisien le monde libération
bfm le jdd tf1 france 2 lci ne se valent pas
je suis même convaincu qu'ils se sont rendus
compte que tous les journalistes ne sont pas
identiques au sein de ces médias certains sont
prêts si d'autres brouillent ont certes un
tout jeune d'autres aguerris que pensez-vous
des journalistes classe et votre confiance par
type de média papier radio télé et web toutes
ces opinions sont absurdes ce qui achève de me
convaincre de la toxicité de ce type de sondage
c'est quand je regarde les médias nés de cette
défiance ces milliers de sites de page facebook de
comptes twitter qui annonce d'emblée qu'ils n'ont
plus confiance dans les médias traditionnels et
que par conséquent ils ont lancé leurs médias
alternatifs info non sourcées usage permanent
du conditionnel rumeurs en veux tu en voilà
désinformation manipulation triche partialité
voilà ce que produit presque systématiquement
la défiance envers les journalistes un grand
n'importe quoi toxiques et dangereux ne vous
méprenez pas je ne fais pas dans le corporatisme
premier degré je n'ai pas confiance dans tous les
médias même au sein de médias que je respecte il
y à des signatures dont je me méfie je vois et
dénoncent comme vous des abus des courts-circuits
des travers des collusions mais quelle que soit
la taille de mon sac à critique je n'y mets pas
et n'y mettrai jamais tout le monde voilà
qui dit bienvenue dans l'atelier des médias